foreign
[Music]
ly filming for Venom 3 has started and
the theatrical release is also as good
as set in this video we'll provide you
with all the information we know about
the project all the people involved what
can be said about the story and about
what's going on behind the scenes it all
started with Venom in 2018 the start of
Sony's Spider-Man universe It Was Then
followed by morbius and Venom Let There
Be Carnage but neither was really
popular with viewers nothing can be said
yet about the quality of the next two
SSU films Craven the Hunter and Madam
Webb so while the fans hopes rest on
Venom 3 to return to its former glory
after all the character's popularity
seems to remain undiminished
the starring role in venom 3 is of
course once again played by Tom Hardy he
plays the reporter Eddie Brock who is
inseparable from the alien symbiote
Venom Sony additionally confirmed two
more members of the cast first we have
British actress Juno Temple who has been
best known in recent years for a role as
Keeley Jones in the series Ted lasso for
the 33 year old British actress this is
the third role in a comic book
adaptation After the Dark Knight Rises
in Sin City 2. since she was cast early
on she will surely play a leading role
the same goes for tuiatel ejiofor whom
we already know from the doctor strange
movies where he played the role of Baron
mordo it is not known yet which
character he will be playing in venom 3.
however we strongly assume that it will
be a new character officially no other
cast members are known as of yet however
since the Symbiote Toxin has already
been teased in venom 2. we anticipate
that Stephen Graham will return as
detective Mulligan he is after all the
human host of the character we're also
eager to find out whether we will
finally get to see Tom Holland in the
Venom movie there have long been rumors
that the two movies series are to be
joined and after Tom Hardy's Cameo
appearance in Spider-Man no way home at
the latest it only seems to be a matter
of time
there are no official details about the
storyline of Venom 3 yet though there
are some hints for example the first set
pictures have already surfaced on these
we see Eddie in the same shirt and
t-shirt he wears in the mid-credits
scene of no way home we recall he was
pulled into the MCU by Dr Strange's
spell and has a bartender in Mexico tell
him about the events surrounding the
infinity Saga Venom recognizes Peter
which may be because the Symbiotes share
a common memory and another venom has
after all already encountered Tobey
Maguire's Peter Parker in Spider-Man 3.
after Doctor Strange undoes the spell
they are sent back to their own Universe
this could be where the plot of Venom 3
picks up if you look at the first set
pictures it will probably take place in
Mexico first more precisely on the Day
of the Dead a world famous Mexican
celebration as a potential new ally for
Eddie toxin awaits toxin is the
strongest symbiote we know so far he is
superior to Venom Carnage and even
Spider-Man in all respects so if he were
to play a part again the movie would
require an even stronger villain than
before we are eagerly awaiting the
official announcement of which character
will be this time
production of Venom 3 is currently in
full swing filming has already been
ongoing since June 26 2023 in Los Mateos
in Cartagena Spain as well as in
kalblanca Regional Park with further
filming planned in London the director
is Kelly Marcel who already co-wrote the
scripts for the two predecessors and is
now directing for the first time in her
career which is certainly a bold step to
rely on an inexperienced director for
Venom 3. then again she knows the
franchise very well thanks to her work
as a writer and she also co-wrote the
screenplay for this movie she was by Tom
Hardy who also co-wrote Venom 2. until
we get to see the first Venom 3 trailer
it can unfortunately still take another
year even though there has been no
official announcement about the film's
release the date seems to be pretty much
decided Sony has in fact recently
announced two Marvel theatrical releases
without revealing the movie titles
behind them November 8 2024 and June 27
2025 given that a release date of
October 2024 was previously targeted
insiders are now very much assuming that
the theatrical release of Venom 3 will
be on November 8th 2024 for the summer
date of 2025 meanwhile people are
speculating on Spider-Man 4 with Tom
Holland of course that would be another
reason to show him beforehand in venom
3. at least for a brief appearance to
arouse the Fan's enthusiasm
now you're up to date on Venom 3. which
villain is on top of your wish list and
do you think Tom Holland and Tom Hardy
would work well together in a movie let
us know in the comments and be sure to
give the video a thumbs up we'll of
course keep you posted on further news
about Venom 3.
[Music]